the phrase I'm too busy you know how lot
of people's I'm too busy I just have
don't have any time I'm too busy to me
I'm too busy really means two things I
interpret it and hold it from way one it
means it's really not that important
when somebody tells you I'm too busy
it's not not that important to them to
get together with you have a meeting
with you suing me to show value or to
it's just simply they're lazy because we
all have 24 hours in a day
168 oh we got plenty of time to get a
lot of things done I have a family I
have two kids I have one on the way I
have a move have all this other stuff
and we still got time today to get up at
5:30 in the morning to shoot a new video
that'll be coming soon to you here so
next time people tell you I'm too busy
or you say that phrase no the two
meanings behind what I'm too busy means
and adjust